hey
hey hey hey what you doing in these
parts
oh i just uh i came by to see the murals
this one's pretty amazing yeah this
one's a beauty
you know in the 1880s there were a few
years that were pretty rough and tumble
in pawnee
this depicts kind of a famous fight
between reverend bradley
and annabeth stevenson a widowed mother
of seven
the original title of this was a lively
fisting
but you know they had to change it for
obvious reasons
she's gotten by the hair pretty good
there yeah so there are ten murals here
in this hallway
and this is called the trial of chief
wamapo it was painted in 1936
and this is chief wamapo and he was
convicted of
crimes against the soldiers i am always
amazed at his
quiet dignity
right before he's killed by a cannonball
i'm surprised no one's complaining about
this
oh tons of people have yeah we get
letters every day
wow oh yeah this is our crown jewel
it's one of our best murals it depicts
the very famous battle at koniga creek
we have a lot of children visit so often
we have to
cover up the more gruesome parts with a
poster
that is horrifying yes it is
in a town as old as pawnee there's a lot
of history in every acre
this wooded area is the site of um
the murder actually of nathaniel bixby
mark
he was a pioneer who was killed by a
tribe of wamapoke indians
after he traded them a baby for what is
now indianapolis
they cut his face off then they
made it into a dream catcher and they
made his legs into rain sticks
and that's the great thing about indians
back then is they used every part of the
pioneer
yes i am a little nervous pawnee has
kind of a
tricky history with welcoming foreign
visitors
but things have changed our guests are
gonna stay in a motel
for sure
so for my painting i chose one of my
very favorite greek myths
the centaur goddess diaphina slaying a
great stack
it's uh stunning it's breathtaking jerry
yeah really is
wow thanks guys hey leslie you should
really come over here and look at
jerry's painting
oh my god
me is that me what no
no oh geez it does look like you you're
just realizing that now
that's what you see when you close your
eyes at night jerry topless leslie glued
to a horse
okay leslie i am so so sorry diaphina
she is this powerful goddess and
i've been thinking a lot about powerful
women and subconsciously i
painted you i'm sorry i'm gonna take it
right down no
leave it up i love it
i don't know how to explain it every
time i look at it i just think to myself
what
can't that centaur woman do besides ride
an escalator and drive a car
art can be so
magnificent oh my god the baby is tom
what this is easily my favorite painting
ever
what the hell jerry look at my pot belly
i look like a pregnant baby
and why am i so scared all right we got
to take this down now no this painting
isn't going anywhere tom
hello fellow lover of the arts
welcome to the painting is that you
know it's hot thank you this guy's in it
too he's the little fat baby
okay as everybody knows the spirit of
pawnee was defaced again last night
what was it this time chocolate pudding
huh that's new
the mural that normally resides here is
called the spirit of pawnee
and it's very controversial we've had
someone throw acid at it
tomato sauce someone tried to stab it
once
we really need better security here we
also need
better less offensive history so the
city council has decided that the spirit
of pawnee should be changed to something
just a little less
horrifying now since the murals were
made by government
employees back in the 1930s we thought
it might be fun if each department
submitted the design for a new mural and
you'll submit your concepts
tomorrow afternoon
wow really good jerry for my murano
i was inspired by the death of my
grandma you said muriel
no i didn't urinal i heard it anyway
why don't you put that mural in the
men's room so people can marinate all
over it
jerry go to the doctor you might have a
urinary tract infection
i just wanted to show you here
[Applause]
it's pointillism and each dot is a photo
of a citizen of the town
no one cares at all
may 1817 a scrappy group of frontiers
men and women arrive at a hard-scrabble
chunk of land
and call it pawnee indiana we owe them a
debt of gratitude
um june 1817 the richest among them
take all of their money from the bank
and then flee up the hill like cowards
to form eagleton
recognize any of your ancestors among
the meanies
actually like most people from the area
i have ancestors on both sides
that's why i think this rivalry is just
a little silly and self-defeating
yeah you may not know this but leslie
was actually born in eagleton do not
blame me for the sins of my mother
in 1849 sarah nelson quindal exposed her
elbow outdoors
which was a class a felony although she
felt the law
unjust she acknowledged that she had
broken it and she nobly accepted her
punishment
to be set adrift on lake michigan like a
human popsicle
look how calm she looks that's how i
feel totally zen
turnbill mansion is one of the most
beloved historical sites in pawnee
in 1867 the progressive reverend
turnbill
officiated a wedding between a white
woman and a
wamapoke indian chief the secret
ceremony was beautiful and romantic
but then word got out and the reception
was a bloodbath
fortunately there were two survivors
unfortunately they were both horses
favorite place
upstairs there's this mural of
wildflowers and i like to sit on a bench
in front of it
really it could be anywhere in the world
paris hawaii
the grand canyon nope just the bench in
front of the mural what about like an
actual meadow where wildflowers are ew
and i'm scared of bees mural hey i never
get to tell you the rest of my ideas you
want to go
somewhere and talk about them yeah yeah
i'd love to um
let me get some actual food and then um
do you know that wildflower mural up on
the second floor
mm-hmm yeah you want to meet there
yeah okay sounds good i don't know if
the online thing is for me
i prefer to meet people in person it's
like
door number two on let's make a deal
do you want the thing that you have that
you know you like
but isn't perfect or do you give it up
for what's behind door number two
i think i like what i have there were a
lot of signs that ben and i should get
married tonight but truth be told
we just really wanted to get married
when you're in love
everything seems like a sign i love my
husband
i love my job and i love my friends
even though they really can't handle
their booze
i love pawnee i will always love pawnee
but london is amazing
and silk borg sounds amazing and
mongolia sounds amazing
their mayor is a professional wolverine
wrangler fine mongolia sounds terrifying
but
the world is a very big place and i've
seen very little of it
maybe we should travel more expand our
horizons
you know i've had the same kinds of
thoughts we should keep that in mind see
where it leads us yeah there's one more
thing i want to try
i got you something in london a
traditional barrister's wig
oh wear it for me yeah
mm-hmm all right
what's up no not sexy failed experiment
take off okay just take it
you